you know it would be really funny as if
in the final battle because they say
that bloodsport uh put superman in the
icu after sorrows only superman comes
[ __ ] and then immediately a starfish
slides on his face
yeah and then it's like which one do we
find
split up where are my kryptonite bullets
i brought the wrong kid
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch
from the king erik voss over at new rock
suicide squad easter eggs breakdown
the galore the master doing his job
we literally just a few minutes ago
finished our live stream spoiler talk
for the suicide squad
big thank you to everyone who joined in
all those who contributed to the super
chats as well it was a
wonderful wonderful discussion it went
on for almost two hours so
really in-depth talk but there's one
thing we know eric vos for doing
is constantly showing us things that no
matter how long we talk about it we
don't
don't pick up on it no matter how wily
and
intellectual we think ourselves to be
eric always notices more let's do this
people i'm so excited
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of james
gunn's suicide squad
a thrilling bloodbath on an island of
broken toys
from the gory visual details to the
music to the dc easter eggs and cameos
i'm gonna break down this film scene by
scene to appreciate the deeper reasons
why this movie feels like such a
redemption and to celebrate the suicide
squad we have some new merch
our latest obsession we gotta talk
before
whatever you buy and i'll buy all all
right jaws poster
i want that no no we've got a whole
bunch of different colors
i want that one brand new nerdy street
wear hoodie
i will default to the king shark
experience
merch.com so the thumb opens on savant a
lesser-known dc villain played here by
michael rooker who worked alongside
james gunn
and the guardians of the galaxy movies
along with sean gunn and sylvester
stallone who voices king shark here gunn
framed savant
reflected in a grimy puddle at first
which is similar to the murky water he
ends up bleeding out into
the music we hear is folsom prison blues
johnny cash's anthem for the
incarcerated giving some hope for
redemption and others
accepting that they are beyond it one of
the first things we were talking about
was like what was the purpose of the
opening shot you gave a really good
answer on that i didn't actually think
about how
that is foreshadowing the death because
like we kind of view the first
team one as like an own short story
about a suicide squad team how's bookend
like he kills the bird and then at the
end of it and his story the birds
eat lunches but then using the puddle as
kind of foreshadowing of that is an
interesting detail one thing that
neither one of us picked up on it's a
nice little dovetail circle around and
the movie's full of those
to start off on one's perfect and such
is the case for savant here who cruelly
kills a bird
trigger warning here if you love birds
like i do
yeah notice how right on the moment of
death the music shifts from stereo in
the mix of the movie to diegetic in the
scene so we're leaving
this fantasy of freedom symbolized by
the bird to
death in captivity just like how savant
will die in prison
the doctor who implants the detonator
chip is played by
john ostrander writer of the suicide
squad comics that gunn wanted to capture
the spirit of with this film
really the reason why this movie can
exist rick flagg returns in the 2016
suicide squad which this movie is kind
of a soft reboot of we're bringing back
rick flagg harley quinn amanda waller
and captain boomerang let no one else
however this movie doesn't erase
anything that happened in the dc films
prior and i would argue celebrates the
best parts of those movies so joining
flag's group
boomerang as well as tdk an adaptation
of the one joke character arm fall off
boy
javelin a green lantern villain mon gal
an alien warrior and daughter to
superman villain mongol
black guard aka richard or dick hertz
who's a villain to booster gold and
weasel played by sean gunn in motion
capture weasel's bright blue eyes
they're gonna be distorted askew
versions of concussion oh
i love that of course harley quinn what
are you doing back in prison house
like a road rage in a bank now the 2016
film ended with jared leto joker freeing
harley from prison but birds of prey
established that they had broken up
and notice how her jacket now reads live
fast die clown
replacing her jacket in the 2016 film
that read property of the joker
way of reflecting her new independence
from him similarly her shoulder tattoo
yeah
the joker now reads property of no one
levants rap sheet lists vigilantism
kidnapping extortion destruction of
property attempted homicide and
production of legal weapons
mongals lister as alien endless mass
homicide war crimes crimes against
humanity destruction of property aiding
abetting and threatening an official
and i love how all of waller's aides
take bets on who's gonna die first just
like we all did the first time we saw
the cavs
your name is letters all knives and
letters [ __ ]
similar joke to the one in infinity war
that's a made-up word who was made up
which was a line written by taiko atiti
for that film
the same guy who later delivers the core
theme of this film as the original rat
catcher harley loves javelin's german
accent
american women all love accents we do
because we don't got none margot robbie
is of course australian she is doing a
heavy brooklyn accent as harley here now
weasel
seems to drown the weasel is dead i
repeat the weasel is dead
yeah notice how on economos's screen he
only now marks weasel in red
basin on savant's call not when he
actually would have expired moments
earlier in the water this explains how
they considered this character
dead despite his later survival in the
post-credits scene and by the way in
that moment he rises under a full moon
calling back black guards missed a
werewolf that's so funny because the
second time i watched this
i was thinking to myself like wouldn't
that something have gone off if he
actually did die
and they have like vitals on them or
something i love how in the background
they are taking care
of that criticism that one would have on
a re-watch that's
good script supervision damn that's a
great attention to detail
parkour screen makes it seem like tdk's
attack is going to be epic and clear the
beach
like yondu's yacca arrow but instead
they just slowly
inch their way in normal human walking
speed up the beach to just pester the
soldiers yeah
this is the moment that the tide really
turns to this battle and they start
dying off one by one
and flag had hardly realized that their
group was set up to be a diversion so
that the other group could take the lead
in the mission
during our live stream one of the most
talked about things was actually the
fact that they killed off boomerang so
early on and just to reiterate this
really quick i think it's really
effective that they killed everyone off
at the very top of the film because it
really does set the stage
that anyone can die killing off one of
your main characters from the previous
one
really helps establish that tone quite a
lot because everyone's death is kind of
amusing and funny that they're killing
all them off but when boomerang dies it
kind of gets you in the heart a little
bit there's even like a shift in music
at that point
where everything's kind of fun and wacky
but when he dies it takes on a bit more
of a heavier tone well yeah
this also sets you up to be very wary
and suspicious of the surroundings your
teammates and the people back home
sending you on the mission just through
all the different elements that lead to
the bloodbath savant's head forms the
title
a trick that james gunn uses throughout
this film kind of a visual equivalent of
making music diegetic making something
that normally is cinematically
expository
instead coming from within the scene and
of course team two
is bloodsport peacemaker ratcatcher two
king shark and polkadot man all villains
are anti-heroes of ranging notoriety in
the dc world on economos's screen tdk
is listed in critical condition so not
dead yet
a style watch you could watch tv on it
said star latch ironically that is what
he has to face
by the end of the movie a latching star
or fish blood sport and peacemaker
bicker over hitting a target
more center than the other i use smaller
bullets what
they go inside your bullet holes without
even touching the side this is exactly
what blitzwork does to peacemaker
in their final duel kingshark reads his
book this is the varieties of religious
experience by william james a
psychological study that looks at
commonalities in different religions
across
traditions they use king shark's
original name in this movie nanoway and
waller says that people believe he was
the descendant of an ancient shark
god maybe nagano was given this book to
see if there is any cross-cultural
validity to his divinity but then again
he doesn't know what he's reading he's
reading it upside down they passed this
female inmate
this is actually kaleidoscope it's
confirmed with movies credits this is a
villain
in the dc comics catcher 2 has a photo
of her father in the cell
so tycho was actually with us in this
movie since the beginning she's always
sleeping in this movie which is a fun
character quirk but she later says
i was having the most wonderful dream i
like to think she could be dreaming
about her old man
and then she sleeps all the time in
order to keep him fresh in her memory i
just love
i forget the actress's name for like
such an [ __ ] do you know it daniella
melchior for
don't say with a question mark you know
for sure are you thinking of rat catcher
too
yes what's that actress well there are
other actresses in the movie but we're
talking about rat catcher you could be
talking you did a great job but you had
a lot of hard work versus
your raiders let me john gunn also
cameos as calendar man a dc
villain arguably best known for his
hannibal lecter style role in batman the
long halloween to the right of him is
this guy with the ace tattoo this is
double down
a villain to the flash space is scarred
because a mysteriously cursed deck of
cards scarred his skin
allowing him to detach the cards from
his body and then use them to slice
people puerto mountain peace is an
island nation in the dc world that
appears in the dark knight returns as a
play superman is sent on a mission and
then the ussr
nukes it but this place also showed up
in tim burton's batman it's a place
vicki vale went on assignment
the name of the fight oh cool norse
mythology is the home of the giants and
the frost giants you'll know it from the
marvel worlds
but in the dc comics it is a fortress
that was built by nazis but in a
different country
of karak fictional middle eastern
country and yotenheim was destroyed by
rick flagg in the first suicide squad
mission waller explains how a military
coup
executed the whole ruling herrera family
and you can notice how behind the
father's hanging body you can see the
feet of a toppled statue that probably
would have been his grandfather or
great-grandfather destroyed when this
coup took place
damn wow that is a
detail mr jesus ross
geez man that is a new rock star's
details
hashtag set design that's like quick
little
eight millimeter footage film reel
look
how did you even see that how did you
get this out all the time
not an hour long as bloodsports team
hikes to the jungle the framing
initially hides polka dot man mostly
behind and anyway in order to delay the
reveal of his glowing rash but you do
see him blowing very briefly very
suddenly on the beach at the start of
the hike but then of course later when
he gets engorged with them and he has to
vomit them out the few that float away
burn the nearby plants just a little
tease of how incendiary these things are
when they're used waller orders
bloodsport to rescue rick flagg
nick flag i know you both served on
special forces incorrectly took down
avril kaduna
again correct that fictional dc country
and avarile kadam is a general who
overtook the country
into deathstroke comics and uh yeah
interesting here in the scene a few crew
people were left visible in the
background
so they raid the cape and they slaughter
friendly militants polkadot man
collapses the watchtower and knows how
one of the dots
burns a hole through the guy's chest and
peacemaker's pacifist dove icon
is appropriately stained with the blood
of his victims we see some archive
footage of astronauts with starro
starro is a long time dc parasitic hive
mind who has plagued the justice league
actually a mechanized version of starro
showed up in the snyder cut you know
what would be really funny is if in the
final battle because they say
that bloodsport uh put superman in the
icu after sorrows only superman comes
[ __ ] and then immediately a starfish
slides on his face
yeah and then it's like which one do we
find yeah
uh split up one of my kryptonite bullets
i brought the wrong kid
then it would have been suicide squad
versus the justice hey
that's part three let's do it that would
be cool part three is superman
the icu for the one thing on his mind
notice how the astronauts
immaturely pose pretending to smoke and
they give these thumbs up they're
evoking the infamous abu ghraib prison
torture photos
in the footage after feeding on the
consciousnesses of three hosts taro has
grown noticeably larger
explaining its gigantic size after
latching onto thousands of corto
malteseans
luna courts harley quinn in a kind of
evita scenario but really is a further
fu to the united states but notice how
this romantic montage switches suddenly
from the surreal back to the real
again the switch to diegetic music
reflects the return to reality harley
ends up killing luna out of a promise to
herself to kill
any boyfriend who gave off red flags
referencing her growth from her past
toxic relationship with the joker polka
dot man explains how his dots are an
interdimensional virus
my mother was a scientist at star labs
and she was obsessed with turning me and
my brothers and sisters into superheroes
star labs of course the recurring
facility in the dc world it's where
cyborg's father silas stone works and
shows up in the flash a lot and he
reveals that he sees his mother
everywhere my favorite shot of the thing
especially with the mom version of the
shark polling at the butterfly
but also look at that sebastian the rat
is also turtle mother he's wearing the
mother's glasses
i know i never noticed that
the attention to detail both in this
film and in this subsequent video
is is really is quite warming into my
heart
one of the times i've seen it on imax
that i didn't catch that's hilarious
okay it's a gift that keeps on giving
you guys didn't see my video where i did
this interview with this short one when
margot robbie and david dust mulching
play as polkadot man
because we don't know what led
polka dot man to being captured by
waller specifically and thrown into the
you know as the journey that led him
here so i asked him if he'd ever want to
do like a standalone movie explore his
origins
he revealed that he was diagnosed when
he was younger with the disease called
it's like develops like skin patches on
your development patches
yeah yeah i was going to say it john i'm
sorry geez oh
i remembered it you know how hard it was
to remember for me to remember the word
vitiligo i thought
we talked about the interrupting
how often do i get the chance to say a
big word
frequently lately your vocab is not
enough huge these days you know
how many people say the word vitiligo
people don't have
i was trying to explain it first in case
the audience wasn't aware of a video
like
it was all going so anyway that's why a
role was so personal for him and he
would love to do a solo movie to explore
kind of the body horror elements and
make something very personal from facts
you know i've already but
yeah yeah hire that woman again to talk
with us
milton has a peanuts lucy keychain which
i like because he is kind of the charlie
brown of this group
rick flagg changes into a shirt with a
cartoon rabbit holding a sign that
translates to
obstacles or opportunities which you
might interpret as a nod to james gunn
turning his temporary firing from disney
into this wonderful opportunity to
revitalize the dceu
i would love it if that's why james
gonna put that in there
it was a little new to the situation and
i think he's i can't remember what it
was but i think he said it was
originally something else he thought
would be too much and then they landed
on that i mean it does kind of look like
a janky bug's bunny meets mickey mouse
so waller references playing golf with
senator cray and not to senator joseph
cray from ostrander suicide squad who
sold government contracts
and when economist asks her if she'd
really harmed bloodsport's daughter
she says you don't know half of what i
would do john
maybe referring to the 2016 film when
she offs pretty much all of her aides
making this a kind of threat to him cleo
and bloodsport share some memories of
their fathers
if i didn't finish a task right he would
dole out the punishment
notice how peacemaker smirks here waller
did say that both of them were trained
from a young age to be killers by their
dads and the peacemaker spin-off series
that the second post-credits scene sets
up will feature robert patrick as his
father they arrive at the lagatita play
or the lovely kitten in portuguese and
as peacemaker enters he bumps into
this old man this is a cameo by director
lloyd kaufman james mentor
no way prisoner in guarding the galaxy
and dancing on stage in red is a cameo
by tom clemente who plays mantis in the
mcu polkadot man later sees the dancers
around him as his mother and i love how
they keep the blue tipped
beard on the one on the left and major
props by the way to actress lynn
ash for selling 11 distinct versions of
the dancing mom now bloodsport
surrenders himself in flag and
peacemaker over to the authorities
knowing from his
in flag's shared combat experience and
peacemaker's similar upbringing that the
three of them
probably all know the death's touch
maneuver then as they drive in to save
harley bloodsport makes fun of
peacemaker's helmet calling it a toilet
seat
it's not a toilet seat it's a beacon of
freedom remember when we first met
bloodsport
he was cleaning the prison toilet seat
so really he was dissing peacemaker's
shiny helmet while complimenting his own
skills at scrubbing something
so until it's that shiny the guy
torturing harley quinn responds to the
text reading what are you doing with
emojis indicating he is electrocuting a
woman in a red dress which brings him
joy now the music that plays over
harley's escape is a mix of just a
giggle oh and i ain't got nobody the
song that she was singing before
so now that it's playing in the audio
mix we're back in harley's subjective
point of view so all of her kills are
seen as super stylized
with all this surrealism taking the form
of flowers and
animated creatures similar to how she
would envision herself as marilyn monroe
in birds of prey
you could see some cartoon rabbits
spinning around her and the birds that
were following her are now a little
scared of her they hide behind the
pillar as she exits
even outside in the cab the animation
continues out of focus in the hallway
back inside
again this one thing that when i first
saw this one the first things i said was
i think james gunn seamlessly
hops in and out of perspectives
throughout this whole movie
in a way that only jane's gun can do
that's one of my favorite things about
it
as like picking up on the audio cues of
the music is something that
i didn't realize were probably playing a
subconscious factor that's so
fascinating to me
filmmaking so they briefed the thinker
we failed admission
you died we find out any information you
give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license please
you die what no remember in suicide
squad mr
j had personalized plates so another
example of how hartley hates anything
associated with him they make it into
the yotenheim tower
you see german words line the walls you
see descartes
or the map of reason and then later in
another angle
de taten or the actions of all humanity
i'm not certain but since this tower was
built by the nazis i'm assuming this is
part of some sweeping progress focused
justification of their cruel human
experimentation
and they find the drones and foreign
subjects
and the thinker reveals that this was an
american-funded operation
and now when we see the nasa astronauts
the red white and blue of the flag patch
is more saturated than it was in the
footage before
recalling the huge flag in the opening
minutes of this movie reframing the
whole
mission as one to preserve murica flag
and peacemaker fight over whether to
release the hard drive to the public and
the press
and gunn shoots this fight in the
reflection of the helmet i love this
shot
because somehow they kept the camera
from appearing in the reflection which
is probably a mix of camera
blocking but also the helmet design the
way it was curved but also probably a
bit of the effects in there milton
dies oh and bloodsport and harley
tragically barely remember him as being
part of the group which is super messed
up because he just held the door open
behind him for harley to follow the
charges blow up early
and win another wave friends attack him
bloody water gushes up which is just
like how it looked when the great white
was the attack
and down below he attacks the soldiers
biting off one's head and is later seen
gnawing the rest of the flesh off his
skull bloodsport aristocats down the
floors of the collapsing tower just in
time to save cleo with smaller bullets
now giant staro's rise from the debris
is nuts but i love how gunn leans into
the insanity with the scott pilgrim
style title decks
star wars scream at them just like the
screaming invasion of body snatchers
yeah
finally steps up as a leader as amanda
waller promised she would turn him into
but actually in this case in spite of
what waller wants him to do in this
moment he helps polka dot man see staro
as his mom gets him to burn off one of
its legs to immobilize it but
he dies a superhero just like how back
in the briefing room he said he wanted
to die on this mission bloodsport fights
through the infected
and he pulls off pieces of his armor bit
by bit to turn them into weapons until
he runs out a cool way of reflecting his
character stripping away his armor to
become more vulnerable
cleo beacons thousands of rats with
composer john murphy's amazing track
called ratism
as this also becomes a baptism for blood
sport as the rats wash over him and the
music uses a children's
oh that's great i love that
eye but really it's the rats who bring
it down by gnawing at the nerve tissue
though really starro's final words are
pretty tragic i was
happy floating
staring at the stars just a reminder
that even starro was once a lowly
innocent creature who was dragged into
this fight by the real enemy cruel
uncaring government
interests the final shot recalls james
gunshot of drax in the closing moments
of guardians of the galaxy when drax
pet rocket to console him but whereas
that moment was about rocket finally
allowing someone else to connect with
him
this is about the broken loner allowing
himself to show
compassion i went deeper into this
closing imagery and the post-credits
scenes in a whole other video go check
that out you can also follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to
rockstars thanks for watching i'll see
you next time bye
love that amazing amazing work eric
boston man i think that shot's great
because clearly that's a core traumatic
memory
for bloodsport of his upbringing with
you know what his dad did to him
his dad made it like help make him who
he is and that he's got a very specific
memory associated
with uh rats and then here it's like
this whole arc that he has throughout
this movie of becoming more vulnerable
doing some heroic steps and then
overcoming that fear
it's just a good character art for the
guy i thought it was great and sebastian
number one hero guys subscribe to new
rockstars we haven't done so already you
can subscribe to us hit that like button
check out our spoiler talk if you'd like
go really in depth for quite a long time
last but not least let's do a
lance door just switched to zero on this
if there's anybody
who would be a perfect addition to a
suicide squad my
friend you've got the skills you've got
the tactical know-how and you're under
plus you got that critical element of
heart
you would probably be an anti-hero
somebody brought into bell rev in the
suicide squad and all that jazz for some
kind of misunderstanding because you
were trying to feed your
family and keep the city free of fires
but you know what
you're also good at starting fires and
maybe that could be part of your
suicide squad you know weaponry package
of what you do
physically to bring to the team you know
lance i'm
telling you start committing some crimes
get yourself arrested
uh you know keep on pledging to the
patreon
because uh we got a nicotine
addiction developing over here so we we
if you want this operation to crumble
it's all on you lance
i'm sorry